see I already did the one thing online
but another young I didn't like the one
that I got so if it gives us a different
one I'm not gonna complain
I agree Eagle I really do like it I
think it's great
[Music]
this is a different wand
Phoenix Feather is my core though this
is closer to what I have on Wizarding
World
anyway
apparently not
no
dang it
okay we got another Phoenix Feather
Grapevine 13 inches flexibility supple
let me guess it's also gonna fail
no no lie curious
very curious
[Music]
the first one we tried that would be a
great plot twist it would indeed
yeah this is not the one that I got when
I went on the website so I
I don't know what that's pulling from
but hey it's all good
I am happy with this one
oh hello
it connected to the it connected to the
Android one no way
see we have retro in all caps right
there
all right now that everything's seems to
be working properly I think I can
finally relax a bit here
I just don't know where to put my hands
because I'm having to sit it on my table
here
that's a powerful combination
Ivy is the big bad just like poppy no
way
that's what my name is
she taught me a few spells but
but I can't do them anymore could there
be something wrong with my wand
foreign
why are we here watching this
curious very curious
monster book
allow me my friend
I don't know what I'm doing but
MP replenishes over time okay we've got
three right now
they look tough be careful okay
now my wand is if uh four MP inflatus
can help you control them
oh we just got our first card combat
actions are represented by cards play
cards to cast spells summon creatures
and wield powerful magical objects
your deck can contain potent spells
including those favored by Infamous dark
Wizards
using a card requires MP alright so
looks like it's going to cost three I'm
assuming and we've got four right now
drag the spell card onto your target oh
that's cool
brilliantly done
and then I guess he kind of has like
this auto spell that he's just sort of
casting here tap on the ground
to move moving requires movement cards I
don't have movement cards
okay we just got 30 of them
okay so I can move 29 times incendio is
a good choice when facing multiple
opponents
all right we just got an incendio card
and it wants us to put it right in the
middle there
oh dude that's awesome
careful they're coming right at you
all right let's hit him with an inflatus
so I wonder if that MP just continuously
replenishes or what
foreign
Victory our first Victory let's go
well done
done I haven't seen a young
almost looks like a game ad what do you
mean Dylan
I'm not following I haven't seen the
young Witcher wizard take to their one
that quickly since
I remember everyone I've ever sold Mr
Potter
thanks I couldn't have done it without
your help
hopefully now I won't make a fool of
myself when I get to Hogwarts
you're going to Hogwarts
I'm Ivy Warrington by the way Ivy
Warrington there we go
dude I hate that my name is all capital
it is what it is man
retro lower case was already taken
oh I see what you mean
card collection 5 out of 75 that is an
epic card vintus
shoots forth a powerful Gust in a
straight line knocking back enemies
along its path and dealing damage deals
200 additional damage to Shields
[Music]
monster book of monsters okay that one's
a rare card throws a copy of the monster
book of Monsters the book will Sprint
towards the Target location knocking
back all opponents hit along the way
then begin attacking
atmospheric charm
rare cast of thunderstorm that damages a
single random opponent within its range
each time it strikes applies a heel
reduction effect to units hit
so does everybody get the same first
three cards
were they different
tap to continue
all right I'll post discuss owls with
Haggard before adopting one oh let's go
we get to go get an owl oh wait Ivy you
have something else to say
something about me did change
oh what
I don't remember anything
do I
um
so foggy dude someone casts a memory
charm on her maybe
did you get your wand sorted
same cards gotcha
so yes thanks again for your help
my pleasure
all right Hagrid thought I'd get you a
gift
be new to Magic an owl is mighty useful
you do like owls don't you of course you
did oh yeah
do we get to pick one though yes
let's go dude
hello hello there oh you must be the
student whoa look at this guy oh yes
fond of you I couldn't decide on an owl
so he left it up to you to choose
go on then have a look for yourself
no I didn't mean to do that
okay wait just three choices
no way right
okay we've got the Scopes owl
are small in size and known
for their agility they also have strong
Raptor like claws to catch prey
then we have the brown fish owl
brownfish owls like their privacy and
often live alone near water source
although they appear to struggle while
it's flying they are actually powerful
Flyers that are fast and silent
and then the barred owl the Curious Bard
owl is easily distinguishable from other
owls thanks to the extensive horizontal
and vertical bars on its plumage is it
plumage
and an unusual trilled hoot
[Music]
number three oh man you guys are all
thrown out
hello world says the tiny owl Dylan says
the third one
I kind of like the description of this
one the best
I like that it's it's like a silent
and fast flyer
I'm gonna go with this one
nobody was saying that one so I want to
go with that one want to come with me